I'm really grateful to have the
opportunity to be a part of bringing a
story of elephants to life Megan Markel
opening up about her return to Hollywood
with the Disney Plus documentary
elephant the interview which Megan
pre-taped for Disney last summer aired
on Mondays Good Morning America in it
she reveals why this project is so
special to her I've been very lucky to
be able to have hands-on experience with
elephants in their natural habitat when
you spend time connecting to them in the
other wildlife you really understand we
have a role to play in their
preservation and their safety Megan says
she hopes the documentary will help
people realize how connected we all are
if we had more of an awareness about the
obstacles we're facing I think we take
care of each other this planet and
animals in a very different way the 38
year old recorded her top secret
voiceover for the doc at London's
Pinewood Studios last October
elephant director and producer Mark
Linfield tells ET that her hubby Prince
Harry was there to watch we also had
Harry for the cheap seats suggesting
some alternative pronunciation this is a
site of elephants we rarely see elephant
debuted on the streaming service April
3rd and marks the Duchess's first gig
since she and Harry made their royal
exit on March 31st they've since
relocated to Megan's hometown of LA with
their 11 month-old son Archie where
they've wasted no time getting involved
in their new community amid the corona
virus pandemic this isn't a couple into
a new home that we getting actually
settled into a routine the pair has been
spotted volunteering with Project Angel
Food several times over the last week
here they are on Friday holding hands
while delivering meals to critically ill
people Project Angel Food zigzag
direktor Richard Ayub tells et that it
was Megan's mom Doria Raglan who
suggested they volunteer with the
organization I went on one delivery with
Harry and Megan and they were all about
dianna they were all about service when
you talk about compassion loving Souls
that's what these people are and they
wanted to do it quietly
and they did and speaking of doing
things on the DL Megan and Harry are
also implementing a new media relations
policy on Sunday the couple announced
their plans to cut off four major
British tabloids for running what they
call invasive stories this includes the
Daily Mail the Sun the Express and the
mirror plus their Sunday and online
editions et has obtained the message
Megan and Harry's communications team
sent to editors on their behalf which
clarifies that this is not in any way a
blanket policy for all media so I always
protect my family and now I have a
family to protect according to the
statement the couple's decision to stop
engaging with the affer mention
publications is due to reporting which
they call distorted false and invasive
beyond reason they also added that it
has a real human cost et has also
learned that Megan and Harry insists
that their decision is not a result of
negative reporting rather quote media
have every right to report on and indeed
have an opinion on the Duke and Duchess
of Sussex good or bad but it can't be
based on a lie I won't be bullied into
into playing a game that's they killed
my mother
et has learned that Megan and Harry
didn't want to take this step publicly
because they want to focus their energy
and attention on supporting efforts in
response to Kovan 19 but with their
upcoming nonprofit set to launch and
their ongoing legal action against one
of the tabloids quote it was necessary
to set out a clear agenda Megan and
Harry announced last October that they
were pursuing legal action against
associated papers after The Mail on
Sunday published a private handwritten
letter Megan wrote to her estranged
father Thomas Markel
[Music]